[Música]
en su primer día del viaje oficial a
Estados Unidos el presidente francés
Emmanuel macrón se reunió con la
vicepresidenta de estadounidense y
trataron un tema que el mandatario
calificó como el nuevo lugar de
conflicto el espacio por eso discutieron
la colaboración espacial de ambos países
para combatir el cambio climático y
mejorar la seguridad
Nancy pelosi ya tiene reemplazo como
líder de La minoría demócrata en la
cámara de representantes de Estados
Unidos se trata de hakim jeffreys quien
estará al frente de la cámara a partir
de enero convirtiéndose en el primer
afroamericano en asumir este liderazgo
en cualquier partido del Congreso
y Naciones Unidas pedirá un 25%
adicional de financiación para ayuda
humanitaria en 2023 así el organismo
espera incrementar dicho presupuesto de
41 mil millones de dólares que hubo en
2022 a 52 mil millones para el otro año
todo para responder a las necesidades
que también aumentan
buenas noches y bienvenidos una vez más
a las noticias internacionales de France
24 yo soy María Clara calle y es un
placer acompañarlos
iniciamos con la actualidad de Estados
Unidos porque como ya lo decíamos
previamente terminó el primer día de la
visita oficial del presidente francés
Emmanuel a Washington mientras que en su
reunión con la vicepresidenta camela
Harris se enfocó en la cooperación
espacial a los congresistas
estadounidenses les pidió reformar el
fondo monetario internacional y el Banco
Mundial en este encuentro también hubo
líderes empresariales y allí más joven
enfatizó que era necesario hacer estas
reformas para ayudar a las naciones
emergentes a reducir su dependencia de
los combustibles fósiles en esa misma
línea llamó a que los países del Norte
global financien a las naciones más
necesitadas Y fue así como se enfocó en
combatir las crisis del clima y de la
pérdida de biodiversidad escuchemos lo
que dijo el mandatario
y quiero ser claro No solo como países
ricos debemos hacer nuestro trabajo y
nuestra sociedad
sino que tenemos que cumplir con los que
nos comprometimos en el acuerdo de París
en términos de financiamiento y
financiamiento frente al sur global
y tenemos que pagar nuestra parte justa
todos nosotros
para ayudar No solo a los países
emergentes sino obviamente a los países
pobres y en desarrollo hacer parte de
este juego y precisamente a recibir
ayuda para financiar su desarrollo y
solucionar los problemas del cambio
climático
otra noticia en Estados Unidos es que
Nancy pelosi ya tiene reemplazo como
líder de La minoría demócrata en la
cámara de representantes se trata del
congresista hakim jeffreys quien estará
al frente de la cámara baja a partir de
enero él será el primero afroamericano
en asumir dicho Cargo en la historia de
cualquier partido y con él llegarán a la
mesa principal la demócrata Catrín Clark
y el latino Pit Aguilar es decir una
mesa sin hombres blancos por primera vez
Andrés granadillo nos cuenta un hecho
sin precedentes la elección de Joaquín
jeffreys como líder de los demócratas en
la cámara de representantes
estadounidense Esta es la primera vez
que llega a este cargo una afroamericano
esperamos encontrar oportunidades para
asociarnos con los republicanos y
trabajar con ellos siempre que sea
posible
pero también nos supondremos al
extremismo siempre que sea necesario
amamos este país amamos nuestra
democracia este abogado años graduado
con honores de la facultad de derecho de
la Universidad de Nueva York representa
la diversidad de los votantes del
partido y abre la puerta un relevo
generacional en su cúpula tras la
renuncia de Nancy pelosi jeffreys
aprovechó para agradecerle por sus años
como presidenta de la cámara baja
quiere transmitirme agradecimiento a la
presidenta Nancy pelosi una obra
extraordinaria para los tiempos que
corren que ha aportado tanto a tantos
durante un período de tiempo tan
significativo
El mundo es mejor gracias al increíble
liderazgo de la presidenta Nancy pelosi
el congresista quien repite por quinta
vez pertenece al octavo distrito de
Nueva York comprende gran parte de
Brooklyn Queens ha estado en el grupo de
los demócratas que aprobaron las grandes
iniciativas de Joe biden para la
recuperación económica como el plan de
rescate estadounidense tras la pandemia
de Kobe 19 la ley de inversión de
infraestructura y la de reducción de la
inflación para para la siguiente
legislatura también fue elegida
Catherine Clark como número 2 de la
bancada del partido
y hoy fue el segundo día de la Cumbre de
la otan en Rumanía allí el secretario
general en noruego James stoltenberg
reiteró su ayuda a Ucrania Indicó que lo
más inmediato y urgente es ayudar al
país a prevalecer como un estado
independiente y democrático para así
poder abordar la posible adhesión a la
alianza militar
esto financiará un apoyo no letal
urgente que incluye combustibles y
generadores
lo que ayudará a Ucrania a abordar las
consecuencias de los ataques de Rusia
contra su red eléctrica
y a propósito de la guerra en Ucrania
este es uno de los hechos por los que la
ayuda humanitaria ha tenido que
aumentarse ante el panorama del
secretario general de asuntos
humanitarios de la ONU Martin griffits
anunció que pedir a un incremento del
25% para el presupuesto del próximo año
en comparación a lo que solicitó el
organismo en 2022 sin embargo la
financiación actual está lejos de lo que
piden Gabriel colchén nos cuenta
una necesidad de ayuda humanitaria que
aumenta año tras año este miércoles el
secretario general de asuntos
humanitarios de la ONU Martín griffith
anunció que la organización pedirá un
25% más de financiación para 2023 para
llevar a cabo operaciones de ayuda
humanitaria en todo el mundo y así va a
subir alrededor del 25% Y eso es
impactante Pero ha subido cada año un
25% en los últimos años Así que lo que
esto significa es muy muy simple y es
una simple suma de hecho que la brecha
entre las necesidades y la financiación
va a crecer pero cada año y a pesar de
las demandas alarmantes de la ONU la
financiación está lejos de alcanzar el
presupuesto necesario entre los países
más necesitados están somalia y Etiopía
donde aunque no sea declarado
oficialmente la hambruna sus habitantes
están muriendo de hombre por las sequías
la invasión rusa a Ucrania también
contribuyó al aumento de humanitaria
además de haber las
exportaciones ucranianas de grano al mar
Negro también detuvo un óleoducto que
transportaba armoníaco un ingrediente
clave para los fertilizantes
esencial como nos dice nuestra gente en
la industria de la seguridad alimentaria
si no utilizamos fertilizantes ahora
tendremos un problema de disponibilidad
de alimentos dentro de un año Así que es
enormemente importante casi más
importante que el grano entre los otros
países en situación de alta
vulnerabilidad está organizada donde la
mitad de la población depende de la
ayuda humanitaria o yemen y Siria que
sufren guerras desde hace años
la comisión de la Unión Europea propuso
este miércoles un paquete de medidas que
buscan reducir el consumo de vasos de
plástico de un solo uso y también la
cantidad de plástico que se utiliza en
los empaques de productos pedidos en
línea la forma en la que se entregan los
cafés en las panaderías y cafeterías
será el primer gran cambio en el día a
día de los europeos Juan Pablo
lucuminosa
una nueva propuesta de la Unión Europea
para reducir el desperdicio de plástico
la comisión europea propuso normas más
estrictas para la reducción de uso de
envases y limitar el uso de materiales
para los empaques de entregas en línea
Todo bajo el gran objetivo de cero
emisiones netas para 2025 Pues esta meta
estaría en riesgo si no se toman medidas
contra la contaminación que a su vez
aumentan las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero
la forma en la que se empaquen los
productos puede y debe hacerse mucho
mejor Creo que todo el mundo lo ha
experimentado pides algo en línea y
vienen una caja enorme que está medio
vacía o contiene capas dobles para que
el producto parezca más grande de lo que
es o vas a una cafetería Y en lugar de
que te sirvan en platos normales te dan
comida y envases de un solo uso el
exceso de embalaje es una molestia para
nosotros y cada vez más dañino para
nuestro medio ambiente
con la propuesta el bloque comunitario
Espera que para 2030 la reducción de
residuos de envases per cápita sea de un
5% y que llegue el 15% para 2040 En
comparación con los niveles de 2018
ciertos envases de plástico como bolsas
de té cápsulas de café bolsas de
plástico ligeras y etiquetas adhesivas
deberán ser compostables
nuestra propuesta tiene como objetivo
tres cosas primero reducimos el empaque
donde es necesario en segundo lugar
queremos que hayan más empaques
reutilizables por ejemplo para 2040 la
mayoría de cafés para llevar vendrán en
una tasa reutilizable o haremos que cada
uno traiga su taza y tercero todos los
vasos deben ser fáciles de reciclar o
que estén hechos de material reciclado
el proyecto necesita la aprobación del
parlamento europeo y los gobiernos de la
Unión Europea para convertirse en ley
así llegamos al final de este
informativo continúen viendo frases 24
[Música]